all right helpsters our goal is to help
me and grandma gracie have a picnic now
who's got an idea huh uh-huh you will
need something to sit on at the park
perhaps a picnic blanket i
hear it and i like it me too so that's
job one
get a picnic blanket for the park all
right what else to carry all the food
and drink you will need a picnic basket
oh yeah we do and i mix job too
find a picnic basket once we have a
basket you're gonna need to pack your
lunches in it ah scatter you always come
up with the most delicious ideas job
three
pack a picnic lunch grandma gracie we
have our place oh right
we've got the plan got the plan we've
figured it out we've got the plan what
happens when we've got the plan we give
a heavy shot just cause we can't
that's very satisfying yes it is lovely
work ladies and good news i have found
some picnic blankets come along all
right come along oh great let's keep
lively
i just finished giving the picnic
blankets a fresh wash
oh and there they are
done this is exciting
oh no the red blanket has shrunk
not to worry i have a yellow blanket oh
yellow's good
and here it is yes oh no
the yellow blanket has shrunk not to
worry i've got another red one which
says shrunk ah they've all shrunk
i've ruined the picnic wait i have an
idea what if you sew the tiny square
blankets together to make one big square
blanket whoa
grandma
and i know this sequence we should put
the squares in sequence uh it means the
order in which things happen uh grandma
please follow my commands okay okay okay
first place a red square on the table
next place a yellow square next to the
red square
next place a red square next to that
yellow square
last place a yellow square next to that
red square
very nice thank you
okay and now we can do the next row so
first place a red wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute
if we're going to do the same thing over
and over then we can just loop and you
don't need to say all those steps let's
loop loop means to do something again
and again so we need four rows so we'll
loop three more times oh allow me huh
[Music]
and
finished
[Music]
find a picnic blanket for the park
check one job done two more to go
cody run mcgracy yeah i am ready for you
in the other room now okay we're on our
way heart come on grandma i shall stay
behind and make sure this blanket does
not get shrunk i found a basket
[Music]
oh heart i'm so sorry i should have been
clearer with my instructions that picnic
basket is way too big
this is not the picnic basket
it's not no this is the
hot air balloon basket to get to the
picnic basket
did you join me
sure
so uh
by the way heart
where are we going denmark
[Music]
welcome to denmark here's your basket
thank you find a picnic basket
check two jobs done one more to go
okay scatter here's the basket ready for
packing and here's your food ready for
eating ah that looks crumbs i'll put
them in the basket
oh no
the lid won't close
picnic cancelled
well well wait a minute buddy bud now
let's debug v-bug oh we call problems
bugs yeah and when we find and fix the
problem we call it debugging
well we already have found the problem
the top won't close so how do we fix it
hmm what if we put the food in a
different way huh yes so it doesn't take
up so much space that's right hey
scatter can you take everything out of
there please
first put one water bottle inside the
basket
next put the other water bottle next to
that one
then place the sandwiches on top of the
water bottle then place the carrot
sticks next to the water bottles
last put the plates and napkins on top
of the carrot sticks
and
it fits
pack a picnic lunch
check all the jobs are done
[Music]